Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
So, was macht denn die Unity Media außer wieder rumspacken?
Scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Poggers.
Hat nur ein paar Frames gedroppt.
Zählt doch in Grenzen, oder?
Was?
So, ich muss noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Und ich muss mir ne Hose anziehen.
Also ich hab, ich hab eine an.
Also, so, als wäre ich nackig.
Ich hab, ich hab eine an.
Aber ich hab ne kurze Hose an, das wird mir langsam zu kühl hier.
Und da muss ich noch mal kurz aufs Klo und dann bin ich da, 2-3 Minuten geht's los, weil
geht eh nicht so viel heute, ui, ui, ja, wie gesagt Leute, ich muss mal kurz noch mal
eine Hose anziehen gehen und ich hab nur eine kurze Hose an, ich zieh die lange Hose an
und ich muss doch mal kurz aufs Klo und dann bin ich am Start, 2 Minuten.
So, ich hab jetzt die kurze Hose an, ich zieh die lange Hose an und dann bin ich am Start,
2-3 Minuten geht's los, ich zieh die lange Hose an und dann bin ich am Start, 2-3 Minuten.
So, ich zieh die lange Hose an und dann bin ich am Start, 2-3 Minuten geht's los, ich zieh die lange
Hose an und dann bin ich am Start, 2-3 Minuten geht's los, ich zieh die lange Hose an
und dann bin ich am Start, 2-3 Minuten geht's los, ich zieh die lange Hose an